joining us down the damp at show Andy
staples covers college football for
Sports Illustrated also knows his way
around a restaurant - Andy can you
explain to everyone the new red shirt
rule and how it directly affects what's
going on today at Clemson and also we'll
talk about Alabama in a second
absolutely so the coaches have been
pushing for this rule for almost 20
years now that they wanted a way to say
hey we can play some guys for a little
bit of the season but still red shirt
them and the reason they wanted that is
you know if you got some guys hurt
toward the end of the year you didn't
want to have to let's let's say you had
three defensive tackles and your backup
gets hurt and the third guy is a guy you
wanted a red shirt and the backups out
for one game and it's the 11th game of
the season and you don't want to have to
play your starter for the entire game
because that's not safe for him right
well they said let's do this rule so
that they can play four games and as
long as they play four or fewer games
they can richer
and so they push that through and they
finally got it passed this year and so
one of the kind of side effects of this
rule is especially if you're a graduated
senior or a guy who is about to graduate
and Kelly Bryant graduated in May you
can kind of dip your toe in your senior
season and then say you know what I'm my
role here is not what I want I'm gonna
shut it down and I'll go to another
school next year and play immediately
one more year because there's also a
graduate transfer rule you know if you
transfer as an undergraduate you have to
sit out for a year but if you've already
graduated you can you can go somewhere
and play immediately so Kelly Bryant can
go play in another school all season
next season and he's got that year
instead of having to sit behind Trevor
Lawrence for the rest of this year in
his college careers over but but Dabo
Swinney the coach of clemson knows this
rule and he I have a theory that you
know in any other year he would have let
Kelly Bryant start one more game so he
could keep both as quarterbacks but
because they have Syracuse who's way
better than they probably were when they
scheduled them four years ago he has to
go with this now and risk losing his guy
I have another theory
maybe devilís we needs a decent human
being and he wanted to give telly Brian
a chance to do this if you wanted to go
with my theory have you hi are you new
to college football yeah I'm pretty sure
if dabble wanted to be that guy and
there's a lot of coaches out there who
would be that guy he would have started
Kelly Bryant this weekend and then said
Trevor's a guy from then on but instead
he gave him a chance to decide what he
wanted to do because like he said he
does love the kid he spent four years
with the kid interesting and the guy's
got everything he's asked somebody
better just showed up so you know a
similar situation Alabama with Jalen
hurts and twoa what's the latest with
their QB situation well Nick Saban said
last week that he intends to keep
playing Jalen Hertz and Jalen Hurd's
isn't going to redshirt we've not heard
anything definitive from Jalen Hertz yet
and we haven't heard anything definitive
from Nick Saban this week you know they
talked Monday I believe he talks again
this afternoon I'd be curious to see
will they come out and say something
because body language everything that
we've seen so far suggests that Jalen
Hertz is going to stay at Alabama and
play the rest of the season now he's in
a different situation than Kelly Bryant
because he's a junior so he has one more
year next year no matter what it's up to
him when he's deciding you know this
week if he wants to do anything does he
want to play two years somewhere else
but he could just write this season out
and then in January say okay do I want
to stay at Alabama for one more year or
lower to go play somewhere else one more
year because he graduates in December so
it's a complete similar it's very apples
and oranges - what's going on at Clemson
Nick Saban's been spending his entire
offseason trying to keep both guys
because of how it worked out last year
yeah and two years ago actually I think
it's probably the one next David is
really worried about because in 2016
when Jim who took the starting job as a
true freshman he said Oh Blake Garnett
transfer I believe after week four and
then they had a couple other guys Cooper
Bateman a david korn well that
their transfers going into the playoffs
oh really there was one scholarship
quarterback who planned to be at Alabama
as they went into the playoff and that
was that's not a situation you want to
find yourself in now clemson has a guy
named chase Brice who was a highly
recruited guy who you know could you
know could be a very capable back oven
could be a starting quarterback at quite
a few places so he would slip into the
backup role behind Kelly Bryant now the
thing is he hasn't been trained to be
the backup all all offseason so they're
if they have to go to him let's say
Trevor Lawrence gets picked up in a
gamer or gets hurt and has to be out for
a while that's gonna be a crash course
for him we're talking to Sports
Illustrated's Andy staples Andy I don't
know if you noticed and wasn't in today
this is the Dan that's been quiet
okay with Dan is out so I have an
opportunity here i caller called in the
show and bet any of us will Dwayne
Haskins the Ohio State quarterback win
the Heisman I took him up on the action
I was the guy so we're betting a shower
shame now if you tell me I should weasel
my way out of this bet
I will talk to Dan tomorrow and take
away a you're saying you're saying
Dewayne Haskins will win the Heisman I'm
saying he won't I have the field the
caller has trained a skill good know
there is a there is a chance to win
Haskins womanizing I mean he's really
really good and you know that the
numbers he's putting up or video game
numbers and he's kind of opened that
offense up in a way that JP Barrett
couldn't he's like here's here's where
I'm with you there's a guy named to
Otunga by law and he's amazing and
there's a guy named Tyler Murray and
he's amazing and there was a guy named
Tracy surly and he's amazing so I think
you are there's a very good chance you
win your bet but your caller does have a
shot hey Andy I know you do some NFL
Draft is Dwayne Haskins an NFL guy we're
hearing a lot about Justin Herbert yeah
the worry at Ohio State is that he's a
want it done as a starter because I mean
physically he's what they want and then
you you
watch his pocket presence and and his
arm and yeah he's a guy the NFL teams
will love now the question is will he
come out this year or will he will he
decide because this wouldn't be one of
those where you see some guys kind of
evaluating class and evaluating who
needs a quarterback and deciding is this
the year I come out or is not just a
herbert of organs a prime example of
that his brothers come into play at
oregon and so he'd kind of like to play
with him at oregon but if he's going to
be the number one pinky you kind of have
to go so you know that that's it will be
interesting as we go forward to see how
these guys evaluate because Dwayne
Haskins is an NFL guy it's just a matter
of when does he does you want to do it
after this he's already one point over
here and he going to the highest
manments west virginia quarterback will
Grier you know he's got the hair the
looks he's got a little swagger to him
he finishes the season Texas TCU
Oklahoma State and then head to head
against Kyle Emery in Oklahoma that sets
up or boom or bust for him for the
Heisman oh absolutely their schedules so
ridiculously back loaded now watch this
game this week though this is an
interesting one West Virginia is going
to Lubbock to play Texas Tech Lubbock
does weird things to quarterbacks who
come in you know from the other team
it's it just it has strange things
happen to them but this is a game that
could be like melt your face like that
the Baker Mayfield Patrick mahomes game
a couple years ago that I think it I
think the final score was 60 65 to 58 or
something like that and they combined
for like 1200 passing yards and a
million touchdown watch that because
Texas Tech is a true freshman
quarterback quarterback named Alan
Bowman he did not win a certain job at a
camp but their starter got hurt and he
came in he's thrown for over a thousand
yards in the past two weeks and I
believe 9 or 10 touchdown passes so this
is going to be a big test for will Grier
because they're gonna have to keep pace
with Texas Tech's offense Andy staples
Sports Illustrated also Andy we've had
John many times talking about college
sports and food at si eats if you want
to follow Andy's tours around the
country now real quick question on not
the best tailgate but the best college
football town for eating so not the
actual tailgate but the town itself
well here's the thing we got a
disqualify places like Austin and
Madison because they're not traditional
called they're great talented and Fantan
leonor two of the best eating towns in
America but they're also the Capitals of
their states so you know that there
there's more going on there there's a
reason there's more going on then do you
have to cancel Baton Rouge big big good
sized town and maybe I know Capital and
I'm canceling Lincoln and Tallahassee
hidden sorry guys but if we're talking
pure knowledge towns
I think Athens Georgia is probably the
way to go just for sheer number great
places because you got the you know the
pulled pork hash at mama's boy and the
cinnamon rolls are the size of a
football you want to go fancy go to five
and ten you get the the chicken and
waffle sandwich at the world famous you
go to Cali and Chios where you you know
buy your beer at the candy store next
door and bring a nice chest right you go
get some barbecue Pulaski Heights three
happens Georgia's probably one would you
put Oxford Mississippi as the top five
seat oh yeah yeah Oxford fantastic John
currence is is the chef who's pretty
much taken over Oxford his places are
City grocery big bad breakfast rain I
think is one of the one of his spots and
then of course you got Ajax diner which
is you know maybe the best meat and
three in America Wow
strong statement by you would it break
it down staples I don't have many gifts
but my ability to eat stuff is pretty
much the only one Dan never would have
never let you going on for this long
about food so enjoy it
that's a substitute teacher this would
have been a tight eight minutes and I've
got a Daily Show now on Sirius XM so I
do understand when the guest starts
rambling sometimes you got to cut them
off so I appreciate Dan for keeping me
tight you redeem yourself for the food
records Andy staples an aside thanks for
joining us the Dan Patrick show for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on Direct TV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
you